[Music]
I'm Christopher Hine and this week we're
talking about Oh sake homie wasa so what
is the Oh sake home he wasa the host
economy was is a set of pinning and
takedown techniques that we use in
Aikido if you're a fan of my style of
Aikido or at least you understand what
I'm generally talking about I'm talking
bout Aikido else they call me waz I
might seem like something that wouldn't
be in our syllabus but it is a part of
traditional Aikido and I believe there's
a good reason it's a part of pretty
traditional like you know but the reason
for that is is different maybe than most
people would think
and so in Aikido our ideas of pinning
aren't so much about dominating a
situation as taking taking advantage of
an opportunity that has arisen for us so
we're going to talk right now about the
differences in types of pins and we'll
talk about the differences of
traditional style jujitsu pins versus
modern style jujitsu pins and we're
gonna contrast and compare that to
aikido pins and why Aikido pins are the
way they are and understand the darson
sacrifices made 90 depends but IQ pins
are actually exactly perfectly designed
for what it is we want to do in Aikido
so IQ depends work perfectly for what
they're designed to do and may get Josh
over here we're gonna talk a little bit
about the basic pins in Aikido all right
so we're gonna talk about the pins and
Aikido the osnomian was up
IQ pins are a nice thing to have in the
system i we don't really start working
on them heavily in our school until
second q and the reason for that is
because understanding pins takes a lot
of responsibility in my opinion and that
sounds weird like I'm being you know
overly dramatic but what what I mean is
when you start training in Aikido you
need to divorce your idea your yourself
of the idea that IQ is about dominating
someone else right so that's another
kind of system like systems like
jiu-jitsu or or boxing or kickboxing
something that stuff is about dominating
other people and if you want to learn to
dominate you should learn those system
those systems are fantastic for that IQs
for situations where you are not the
dominant force in general right so I'm
not the dominant person so choosing to
ten is something you should do with a
very level head right so there might be
a specific situation that we need to pin
I am significantly more powerful than
the person I'm dealing with in order to
keep them or me from getting hurt or
anyone else from getting hurt a pin is
the best thing to do right now so that
might be a situation where it comes up I
often give the the situation of you know
I'm teaching fifth grade and one of the
kids pulls a knife out of the backpack
and does something and I need to hold
that kid down and tell help can arrive
and we can we can get that situation
secured and so I might need to pin
because the kid is well within my
ability to control them they're not
stronger than me so I can still I can be
dominant over the top of them but
understand that IQ depends is something
you're doing kind of as a last resort it
can help you control the weapon and it
can help you disarm the weapon in ways
that would be more difficult if you were
both more autonomous by standing up but
in general they're what we don't want to
use they're what might just happen right
and they're there at the end of the
forms because it's the last thing I want
to do quite honestly so we're in talk
kind of about the pins now the first
thing to understand is the difference
between a modern style jujitsu pin or a
pin you might see in some kind of
Western wrestling system or the kind of
pin you would see in classical martial
arts like popping classical Japanese
jujitsu or even akima historical
European martial arts of pins that you
might see they've got different
objectives and these objectives might
seem really weird to you so first of all
all of our takedown methods the majority
of our takedown methods in Aikido are
gonna be done with arm control right so
meaning that I'm gonna have his arm in
some way to take him down and control
him so when a billion takedown it's
gonna be from the arm now the arm is not
the best way to take someone down the
reason is because his Center is not
directly attached to his arm so while
I'm trying to take him down he can move
his Center in all kinds of position it's
gonna be really hard for me to deal with
it would be much better to take him down
by getting a hold of a sinner or getting
a hold of his leg that's a better way to
take someone down the problem with that
is if we're talking about weapons as you
would see in classical historical
European martial arts or in Japanese
jiu-jitsu if I don't account for those
arms he's got an arm free to stab me
right so if he's stabbing me right now
hitting me that would suck but that's
not nearly as bad as to be stabbing me
right so if I was like this
and that's killing me every single time
he's doing that I'm dying a little bit
more right so so I can't deal with this
guy and try and take him down without
first having control of that arm so
you're gonna see lots of pinning or
taking our methods that involve that arm
now once we get down with that says
let's say we just do a basic detail here
okay so we got a basic detail and you
look at a position like this now a
position like this might seem like a
dumb position right it's like this is
not the greatest controlling position
but now think of what I've done first
first thing I've done is I've isolated
this hand from the other one which is
fantastic for me because by doing this
kind of pin he can't reach across with
the other hand and switch right you can
try any way he wants the switches okay
now let's say he had another weapon he'd
probably have to recover it from there
and by the time he's doing this I can
get over here to control this so we're
thinking about arm control and weapon
control this is the kind of pin you
might want to have right so it might be
done in this fashion it might be done in
this fashion there's lots of different
ways we can go to it but these are the
classic kinds of pins you would see in
traditional Japanese jiu-jitsu or any
kind of armed system versus an unarmed
system all right now if we're talking
about unarmed methods right my takedown
methods are probably just going to
involve the core of his body because
that's the easiest and best way to take
him down
so I come in here like this and I take
this guy down right and from here in
this position I'm gonna shirt to control
him now in a modern sports system what
are the ways you would see to control
someone you might see some kind of cross
body position like this okay
you might see a top dominated mounting
position like this you might see a scarf
hold like this right scarf will being
the best of those in my opinion permit
from how those work but this is a anime
for me but what what you've got to
understand is those pins do not as
nicely account for the hands as the
armed pins do right now there is an
advantage to security and when we get
into the next section talk about
autonomy and security in Aikido you're
gonna see that there's another big huge
advantage but when I'm here like this
let's say I have Josh's hand here and
I'm gonna do some kind of American lock
something like that he can still
Chopra with his other hand and switched
so he got that switch in now if I'm real
clever I might be able to keep you from
doing that but that hands available now
if he had a knife that I didn't know
about in that other hand he's already
gotten that night and he's going to work
with it right all he'd have to do is
slide into his waist pull that knife out
now if I'm in this kind of position and
he goes to his waist to pull that knife
out now I start to pull that knife out
I've got to drop everything and go to
this hand and he's coming up and I'm
losing a lot of security over the arm so
it's a bad position from a top mount
position I really don't have that kind
of arm control again right so let's say
he has a knife in play and I've stopped
the knife here if he can manage to get
that to the other hand now I'm chasing
it over here right so I'm doing a lot of
work back and forth back and forth back
and forth between these now our weapon
on control is not the most important
thing in our pinning differences between
modern styles and in Aikido but it's one
of the key factors you always have to
understand that I do pins are counting
first and foremost for the hand now in
something like a like a scarf hole I
could account much more for the hand
right now something like a scarf hold
done this way comes from classical
systems of Japanese jiu-jitsu if the
goal of mine is to dominate this guy I
can hold him here and really control
that arm so if there's a knife here now
if he were to go to the other side sorry
if you were to grab a net from the other
side right
I can still cross this over and come
into this position now you'll see us
Shiva often pinning like this from
classical jiu-jitsu styles where he's
trapping one arm underneath like this
and able to account for the other heart
like this so if you were going to use
this kind of pinning technique this is
the way you would do it from an arm's
perspective so the first thing we have
to take in think John the first thing
you have to take into account when
you're thinking of the the pins we use
an Aikido versus the pins you might see
in modern sport is weapon arm control
all of our takedowns are going to be
done from a weapon arm all of our
controlling methods are gonna be done
with the weapon arm as the number one
thing with the secondary weapon as the
number two thing meaning I'm controlling
this but if there's another weapon in
player he switched how would I
immediately control that sports martial
arts are designed and worried about core
control because core control gives you
more security so if the goal is to
dominate the other guy and not have
worried about weapons that I want to do
core control for takedowns and core
control for the pinning methods this is
one of the big things that
differentiates these two ideas and
pinning next we're going to talk about
autonomy versus security and how
important that is I'm Chris fried thanks
for watching